when i saw your new tv show which is on
disney which must thrill you because
you're like a disney fanatic
that makes me happy and the show is
called big shot john plays a basketball
coach
who uh gets kicked out of college ball
because he's
you know a hot head and throws a chair
at people and then he ends up the only
job he can get is coaching a girls high
school
basketball team which is funny but it's
very charming
it's incredibly charming so well cast
this character was a guy who you know
who was on it sat on the page
nobody liked him he was unlikable he was
crabby he was he was not a people person
i mean it's a show about a guy who lets
go of his preconceptions of of
what women are and what kids are what
basketball is and
actually you know changes he fights the
change but he lets it go right
no it's a good part because it kind of
mimics it mimics your life now i mean
you've got you've straightened out your
life
you're living a different kind of life
and then in the show you're learning how
to
you know relate to these girls not to be
a hard ass you're opening up to your
daughter on the show that's a nice
that's a nice relationship between you
and the
the girl who plays your daughter to
learn to be a father too that evolves
and by the
like the tenth episode he he this great
speech where he says i get i get it
that's about sacrifice
you know sacrificing your own needs for
your child and at the end of the day you
don't get a ring
you don't get a trophy but what you do
get is if you do it right
is a more loving a more caring a more
kind
version of you to leave behind the world
and that's you know that's cool my dad
oh so what are you showing me from your
dad you you you went over and grabbed
this uh
what is that on that you grabbed
something off the wall he never wrote
and again he didn't say i love you a lot
because he
my mom did every you know two seconds
you met my mother yeah
i love you i love you yeah you did see
rob she loved you guys
and she would say um she would say my
dad would say
you overuse it if you you know say love
you all the time it doesn't mean
anything
so we were in um i was doing a movie in
yugoslavia when it was yuki's lobby and
i got to bring them
and he when he got home he he wrote a
letter out which he very
rarely wrote and he faxed it to me and i
read it then and whatever and then
when he was dying some 15 20 years later
i was uh i was digging through his stuff
he was a very humble man he drove the
same car
just put a new engine in it but he you
know made sure my you know my sisters
went to college and my mom had a great
life
and uh so i was looking for anything he
didn't but i saw the bottom of this
letter
and it said i love you dad and i said
what the hell like my heart just stopped
and i was what is this
and i read it he said dear jay ay hey
hey what abc
first i want to thank you for the
opportunity to have a great trip and the
view of europe without you we surely
wouldn't have done it
b you made me so proud those three weeks
that my chest is about 60 inches
uh wide right now and and
the way that you handled all the people
around you was fantastic you are truly
head and shoulders above everyone else
and he said see he said life isn't very
long
and a man doesn't have many great
moments but you have given me many
thank you i love you dad this
bad stuff the idea that your father took
the time to write that letter and say my
chest is swelling
with pride over you i think that letter
i i don't blame you for framing that on
the wall
believe me i would frame it too